foreign
[Music]
good evening now it's fair to say it's
not exactly been the dream start should
we say for the new leader of the
Scottish national party first Minister
Hamza Youssef today the party's
Treasurer call him Beatty resigned
following his arrest yesterday and
there's questions too about finances for
the Prime Minister here in Westminster
which you see next wife shares in a
child care firm that could benefit from
a policy in last month's budget were
declared in his financial interests a
little earlier so let's crack straight
on we're going to start with the best
bits of the week so far
the former U.S Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton is hosting a three-day
conference at Queen's University in
Belfast tomorrow 25 years of the Good
Friday agreement well they've
reassembled most of the surviving class
of 1998 to Mark the 25th anniversary of
the Good Friday agreement now there can
be no doubt that people in Northern
Ireland today
enjoy Safety and Security
much more than those who had lived
through the previous decades that they
could have only dreamed of if we can
take inspiration and instruction from
the way peace was achieved 25 years ago
we can fulfill the true promise
enshrined in that agreement we start
with breaking news and the turmoil
within the SNP the party's Treasurer
Colin Beatties stepping back from the
role and also from Hollywood's public
audit committee the party has to get its
house in order that's what the public
would expect it's not helpful of course
I wanted to still determined of course
to articulate what my vision is as a new
leader and a fresh start for the
government economists had forecasts that
today would be the day the inflation
rate finally fell back to single figures
however it wasn't to be it did fall
slightly but it still remains above 10
the UK now has the highest inflation
rate of anywhere in Western Europe it's
absolutely essential that we stick to
that plan and we see it through so that
we halve inflation this year as the
Prime Minister has promised the document
that's dropped is this it's the list of
ministerial interests prime minister
wife invests in a number of companies we
now know one of those but there is
nothing in the prime minister's
declaration telling us what else you
invest in because they've created the
largest Court backlog on record yes he's
letting violent criminals go free
[Applause]
they call himself D soft on
[Music]
they call him Mr Softee but she's seen
it perhaps calling him Mr Softee uh
they're not sure exactly who else but
let's start this evening shall we in
Belfast and the events to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
Bill and Hillary Clinton joined the
Prime Minister Tony Blair and others at
Queen's University in the city from
where I spoke to the Northern Ireland
secretary Christine Harris a little
earlier and I started though by asking
about the news today about inflation
still being above 10 and food inflation
close to double that
um yeah of course I understand how
difficult things are and actually uh um
as a form of fruit and veg wholesaler
um I've actually keenly watched the
price of fresh fresh fruit and veg as
it's been uh rising over the last few
months and that's been one of the key
contributors to our inflation figures
um I'm actually quite confident those
figures will come come down now as as
the seasons change um but you know the
government's been trying to help people
and the the most recent version of that
has been a costaling payment to those
who are eligible that's just gone out
this week one of Russia's next five
Pleasures was to halve inflation this
year are you still confident that's
going to happen
um I I think we are still confident
that's that's going to happen and I
believe
um that I mean I'm pretty sure I'm
trying to remember if it was the IMF or
another forecaster I saw a couple of
weeks ago saying that we should be able
to do that so yes I know that there is
an argument made by some that pay Rises
help to stake inflation but at the same
time can you understand why if you're a
public sector worker and you're seeing
how inflation is rising how food prices
are rising how difficult things are and
your only way to try and effectively
make ends meet is to go on strike you
know you've given nurses five percent
you can teachers four point five percent
inflation is currently over 10 is that
enough
um yeah I mean I I I've obviously not
been involved in those those processes
but um and I'm pleased to see that some
of the unions
um have been settling uh at those levels
but yeah I I'm I am acutely aware
especially here in Northern Ireland
where nurses and teachers sorry haven't
settled at those levels have they nurses
rejected the RCN uh
the RCN Unison rejected it
and and teachers haven't accepted 4.5
either yeah I I mean to me I mean these
are ongoing negotiations for those
unions uh uh uh with the employers and
and the government and um but you know
Unison did accept uh that that level I
but I I am acutely aware especially in
the Northern Ireland context that you
know inflation is troublesome for every
household and
um we have a huge number of people who
are economically inactive uh over here
in in Northern Ireland
um who this is a really tough time for
which is why the government's helping
the cost of living payments that are
coming through
um it it is is equally vital so yeah
these are pressures that are on
everybody though and and uh uh whilst I
know
um probably your follow-up question will
be why why is inflation slightly higher
in the United Kingdom than it is in the
rest of Europe but food is is food
prices that is driving inflation across
the piece yeah but given that food price
inflation is so high shouldn't you be
looking at trying to help public sector
workers who don't have control over
their pay packets because they're spent
by the government yeah and that's that's
I mean this is all part of the
negotiations and as I say some unions
have decided to settle for the the level
of offer that's been given and there are
ongoing negotiations with others now the
Northern Ireland executive is still not
up and running which is an astonishing
extraordinary situation you're the
Northern Ireland secretary do you accept
responsibility or some responsibility
for this failure
um no I think we are trying to find the
solutions to the problems uh the one of
the reasons the main reason that the
Democratic unionist party left the uh
the executive and remember we are here
the backdrop behind me is Queens
University Belfast where we are marking
the 25th anniversary of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement which set up the
institutions uh many institutions one of
the one of the most key ones being the
Stormont the executive uh having mlas
elected
um and stormwatch is run on on a very
different basis to many other
legislators across the world because of
the unique circumstances in Northern
Ireland but it's on the principle of
consent you need the consent of both
communities uh to get it up and running
in the pasture and Fein have collapsed
dormant this time it's the Democratic
unionist party and they were concerned
about the impact of the Northern Ireland
protocol
um I was having here and I'd like to
Think Through The Windsor framework we
have managed to solve a number the vast
number of those issues and now we're
talking to the Democratic Universe party
and Eunice communities
um about getting their politicians back
into Power sharing because that's what
is required here to for the smooth and
effective delivery of public services
and
um and here in Northern Ireland public
services are more challenged in just
about every other place in the United
Kingdom you say that the dep aren't
prepared to enter power sharing because
of the protocol
some would argue that actually that's
effectively a fig leaf that the real
reason they don't want to get it back
into Power sharing is because they can't
stomach the idea of a first Minister
from shimfang do you think that's the
real truth
um well certainly I've heard so Jeffrey
Donaldson say absolutely categorically
and I've got no reason to disbelieve him
but that is definitely not the case
um and um and I've spoken to a whole
host of uh as you would expect dup mlas
and others from the uni from unions
community no that that's I I truly
believe that is not the reason so it's
because they think that the brexit deal
is bad
um I I well what they would like to see
and we we've had this discussion on
panels uh here over the last couple of
days I believe what the dep would like
to see is a restatement by the
government of the United Kingdom about
the importance and the position
of Northern Ireland as an integral part
of the United Kingdom and that's
something I'd like to think I I have
done uh here and the Prime Minister will
do later today now honestly like taking
a political sort of speak away
how close or how far do you think the
dep are from re-entering Power sharing
what is going on in the conversations
and how optimistic are you uh I mean I
mean that's a really difficult one
because
um I I I'm now but I'm now waiting to
hear uh back from the Democratic
Universe party as to exactly what they
would like us to do as a UK government
to uh to kind of restate what we are
doing here the Northern Ireland is an
integral part of the United Kingdom
based on the Belfast Good Friday
agreement uh where we're marking the
25th anniversary here today and will
remain so unless the people of Northern
Ireland want to change that no
politician whose words or or views can
can change that so
um I think you'll find that the
government of the United Kingdom is very
keen and happy to restate how important
it is that and we are how proud We Are
of having Northern Ireland as part of
the United Kingdom but waiting for a
democratic unions Party friend
and colleagues to tell us how they would
like that to be to be stated so we can
do it properly because I'm Keen just as
everybody else is to get to get the the
institutions here up and running
I mean I have to admit that you know if
it was all as simple as just the UK
government saying that we're happy and
proud for Northern Ireland to be part of
the Union I'm sure it would have been
fixed by now it feels to me like
actually there's much more thorny and
difficult issues at stake like the role
of the European courts that in Northern
Ireland for example at what point do you
say look this is not working I'm going
to call another election
um well I've actually I do have the
power to call an election here in
Northern I don't think it would be
helpful at this stage and I have that I
have that power all the way through to
the uh to early 2024.
um so but I to me that is the kind of
the ultimate uh backstop and it's not
something I'd be Keen to do everybody
tells me here that it would just
polarize the situation
um across Society uh more uh than it is
polarized now and that's not what that's
that's not an aim uh that I have or the
government has so we we want the
institutions up and running we've heard
some good words from Jeffrey Donald
Jeffrey Johnson a former MP who is a
high-ranking
MLA Emma little Bengali here at this
conference and I truly believe that we
can get there
um remember it wasn't that long ago that
the Windsor framework
became public as it were and was adopted
it was less than a month ago that it was
actually voted on in the House of
Commons and went through the joint
committee and there's a there's a lot of
there's an awful lot in in the Windsor
framework took a lot of negotiation and
so that's why we've tried to give as
much time and space
um to the to the unions communities and
their political representatives to
digest all that
but I like to think we are getting to
the point where that is you know that is
being well understood that negotiation
between the UK and the EU is over it's
all about implementation and
demonstrating that it does exactly what
it says it does you said this week the
ongoing cellmate installment was the
single biggest threat to the Union what
do you mean by that
yeah so
um so this is one of the uh
Stormont the the executive and the uh
the mlas are one of the key Parts the
key part of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement having I'd like to think that
what we've been able to deliver with the
Windsor framework which does put uh
Northern Ireland in a in a unique
position within our uh Union
helps guarantee Northern Ireland as part
of our Union for a very long time uh to
come and I think when people do not see
their institutions up and running
and public services are falling back
with compared with the rest of the
United Kingdom then they start to wonder
whether whether that institution is
worth having and actually at the end of
the day
um maybe uh you know look to other
places to try and deliver or maybe
believe that another constitutional
setup will deliver those Services we're
not in that space so are you effectively
saying then that you know frustration
with storm one frustration perhaps of
the DP in particular could push people
to supporting a United Island what is
happening here is that you know we've
got local elections in Northern Ireland
that are a tiny bit later than in the in
the rest of the United Kingdom on May
the 18th
um there'll be an interesting test of of
local opinion but you know unionist
communities should be comfortable and in
knowing that they that the the
government of the United Kingdom wants
them to remain a a strong part of our
United Kingdom for as long as they want
to the only thing that can change that
um is uh the people the voices uh you
know the votes of the people of Northern
Ireland
um in the future so they are in complete
control of their own destiny so I
actually think you know the union is is
a strong how as it's ever been and going
to get stronger through what we've
managed to deliver through the Windsor
framework and what I'm trying to say is
that now we need the institutions of the
good Belfast Good Friday agreement to be
up and running to demonstrate to people
that their votes count that their views
count and that democracy counts
while I've got you we've just had the
list of ministers interests drop and I
just want to have a look at the section
from the Prime Minister Rishi Cena
because there has been some questions
about his wife's involvement in a
company called Corey kids and whether or
not there was a conflict of interest
with some of the child care Arrangements
that he's announced so in the
Declaration it says the prime minister's
wife is a venture capital investor she
owns a venture capital investment
company customer Adventures UK and a
number of direct shareholdings it then
goes on to say as the PM's set out in
his letter to the chair of the liaison
committee this includes the minority
shareholding that his wife has in
relation to the company koru kids why is
eonie declaring the one company that has
been outed in the media shouldn't he not
be declaring all of the companies that
his wife has an involvement with to
avoid any idea of a conflict of interest
I mean this I'm afraid Sophie because
this is part of an ongoing investigation
I'm not going to comment on the on this
sort of thing
when when it's when this is all I'm
quite sure things will be completely
clear I'm talking not specifically about
core kids I'm talking about why isn't he
being more open about his wife's
business dealings I think you're being
fairly specific about the Prime Minister
and his interests there's a lot there's
an investigation going on and I'm going
to wait to the end of that
we'll cross it in the house they're
being very careful not to be drawn on
the Corey kids argument let's talk to
Sam Kate said actually a political
editor uh shall we Sam I want to talk to
you a bit more widely about trust and
politics right because it feels like
there's been a lot about this about how
much we should care about it about where
the various scandals are cutting through
the Corey kid stuff the rich you see
next stuff first how big a deal do you
think this is
I mean you're right Sophie because there
just are a lot of issues around at the
moment connected with conduct and you
there were asking the Northern Ireland
secretary about this company Koro kid
that benefited from the last budget that
Jeremy Hunt gave it's part of a package
of funding to nurseries it turns out
that the prime minister's wife actually
has invested in that company and we can
see that declared today here and that's
the story that onskanese we've been
talking about and that's the publication
of the ministerial register of interests
and it makes reference to the fact that
she invests in Finch Capital uh uh she's
Adventure capitalist and that Corey kids
is one of the firms that you invest in
they don't say what the other ones are
because the ministerial uh Laurie magnet
advisor Laurie Magnus argues that would
be too intrusive to her so there is a
sort of question that I suspect just
simply won't be uh resolved about what
happens if uh Prime ministerial spouses
invest in uh companies where there is a
sort of public interest and public
government decisions about that but the
judgment to the government is we're not
going to find out about it but what's
interesting about that story is that of
the three issues around at the moment to
do with conduct I think this one's
probably the least important let's look
at the next one and it's all connected
to one man he is you'll be familiar with
him depth prime minister Justice
secretary Dominic Robb now we could get
the report into his behavior maybe as
soon as tomorrow maybe even tomorrow
morning there has been a long-running
investigation into multiple allegations
of bullying by him at successive
government departments and Rishi sunak
on receipt of that report he's got to
decide whether or not to keep him in his
job although he has said to me before
that if you sound guilty then he'll
reside right so we'll have to find out
whether or not he actually makes good on
that uh tomorrow he's obviously denied
the allegations he thinks that he'll be
cleared what's going to be interesting
about the report is I don't think it's
going to judge whether he is a bully or
not that's going to set out the facts
and then it's going to be for Rishi
sunak to determine whether or not that
breaks the minister code is conduct
Unbecoming and he should go that it's
just worth saying Dominic Raab is the
number two in government he stood in for
Boris Johnson when Boris Johnson was at
death door with kovid and here we are
talking about him nearly departing
companies it's like almost a surprise
that this isn't bigger news but it's not
it'll ramp up tomorrow but even if he
does go will it have much of a record
but even this the second most senior
politician in Westminster possibly on
the precipice about to go is nothing in
comparison to this
this is not just any motorhome right
explain this picture this as you would
know is a nielsman and Bischoff
campervan now this is not the camper van
that was found on the driveway of
Nicholas sturgeon's notification but it
is a campervan but I I didn't want
pictures of tarpaulin and police I
wanted this picture so you can you can
see the type of vehicle at the heart of
the most extraordinary scandal going on
in Scotland at the moment now we don't
concentrate enough sometimes in
Westminster about the Affairs uh uh up
north of the Border nearly as much as we
should but it is extraordinary the
police in Scotland are investigating uh
missing funds it turns out that the
accountants for the SNP resigned the
wife uh sorry the husband of former
first Minister Nicholas sturgeon has
been arrested and stood down as uh
chairman of the party you have the
treasurer stepping back today after he
too was arrested
um and one of the things that has
happened is just turned out that the SNP
owned a motorhome now the idea was that
they were going to spend 110 000 pounds
on a vehicle such as this in order to
take it campaigning around Scotland in
the 2000 and uh I think it was 2021
election campaign now they didn't end up
doing that because of kovitz a bit of a
waste of money but why is it in on
Nicholas sturgeon's husband's mother's
drive it has now been impounded by
police having to useurf the new leader
of the s p found out about all of this
after he was elected he had no idea that
there was a caravan that may or may not
uh have been uh the fruits of wise or
unwise spending by his predecessor but
the problem is there's a black hole
funding unaccounted for it would appear
police investigating it's the kind of
thing that can topple entire penalties
and change the political makeup of a
country that's what labor and the
conservatives are happening I hoping
might happen in Scotland next year it's
extraordinary particularly because it
did feel for a time like the s p were
Untouchable in Scotland and thank you
very much Sam if you're as always we'll
have more from Sam later in the program
you're watching the take we are live in
Westminster up next we're going to be
talking to Lisa nandy Labor's Shadow
leveling Arts secretary
foreign
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's
Midlands correspondent and this is where
I grew up we can reveal that the driver
who hit Harry Dunn is 42 year old am
circulus just met the president and I
never thought we'd get this as far this
is what they're up against
wind is the really the really problems
[Music]
smoke is
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world it's really scary
terrified in this community I'm told
that everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
I never knew they would make it
amazing
it seems tantalizingly close
this corner of the UK Wales was the
first to introduce the plastic bag
charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take we can get the view
now from labor a little earlier I spoke
to the party's Shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa nandy
thanks very much for being on the
program
um let's start with Northern Ireland we
had Chris Heaton Harris on the program a
little earlier and he said he's
optimistic that storm one is going to
get back up and running are you well I
hope he's right and I think he's right
to try and strike that tone we've had a
week where we've been reminded of what
can be achieved on the island of Ireland
what has historically been achieved when
political parties come together and work
together in the interests of the people
and I think he's right to lay down the
challenge to parties across Northern
Ireland that power sharing needs to get
back up and running very quickly who do
you blame for the impulse I I I think I
I don't want to get into the blame game
but I think that the biggest problem at
the moment is that the trust is not
there and when there have been these
moments ever since the Good Friday
agreement was negotiated and then signed
the the thing that has unlocked it has
been the emergence of an honest broker
usually the UK prime minister who has
been able to personally intervene in
order to bring people together and to
resolve the situation and the truth is
and this is you know not a blame game
point at all but the truth and the
reality is that since Theresa May sign
the deal with the dup that has been a
very difficult thing for all political
parties in Northern Ireland to accept
and there is a lot of work to do to
restore the trust to ensure that
political parties in Northern Ireland
all feel that there is an honest broker
in this situation and the person is
really important why isn't he an honest
breaker here I mean he managed to break
a deal with the EU well I I think the
conservative party's record and ability
to manage that process has been
tarnished we're talking about the
current prime minister sure I mean he
was a present feature of that government
all the way through particularly through
the Boris Johnson years he was a very
senior member of the government and I
think that is a problem but I think with
Goodwill with the involvement of the U.S
president which we've seen in the last
couple of weeks with the involvement of
the Irish t-shock and with the
involvement of the UK prime minister and
the will to make this work I think we
could see progress and I think it's
right that all political parties come
together and try Chris Eaton Harris also
said that if people lose faith in the
institutions of Northern Ireland which
will happen if someone doesn't get back
together that could lead to a rise in
Irish nationalism and he describes
that's the biggest threat to the union
is he right I think when people lose
faith in the system itself that you've
got a real problem on your hands and I I
don't want to downplay the seriousness
of what we're seeing in Northern Ireland
and on the island of Ireland but I also
think the is a problem across the whole
of the United Kingdom with people
increasingly feel that they don't have
faith in the political system to resolve
problems for them to make their lives
better and you know might just gently
say to Chris Heaton Harris that the
conservative government Bears some
responsibility for that that the actions
that we've seen particularly of the
Prime Minister the last two prime
ministers that we've had of Liz truss
and Boris Johnson have not gone any way
to restoring trust or confidence in
government and I think it is incumbent
on this Incarnation party what exactly
are you talking about are they that
they're carrying out brexit I mean no
not at all look I I was a remain
campaigner I made no secret of that and
I I wanted us to stay in the European
Union but I accepted the result as did
most politicians at the time and worked
very hard alongside conservative labor
politicians
I think we've eroded trusted I think the
government has eroded trust in politics
I think particularly of what happened
during the pandemic where there was a
government that made the rules and then
broke the rules that lied about it and
laughed about it I think of the promises
that were made around brexit by the
Boris Johnson government in particular
which wish you soon at was a huge part
where promises were made that we would
have oven-ready brexit deals the
situation in Northern Ireland would not
be a problem at all that it could all be
resolved and all political parties in
Northern Ireland feel very betrayed and
let down by that people electing
government so there is there is work to
do talking about trust and politics I
want to talk about the s p as well
because we have seen the situation where
Colin Beatty resigning as SNP Treasurer
after he was arrested as part of the
police investigation into the party
finances how damaging is this I think
the biggest damage is what it's done to
the people of Scotland because at the
moment what they've got is a failing
government at Westminster and a failing
government at holyrood if you look at
what is happening in Scotland at the
moment I think the things that I would
be most concerned about are the record
waiting times for a e the rising
homelessness the record number of drug
deaths all things that are going
untackled because they've got two
failings that are mad in controversy do
you think there's a problem that the new
first minister is seen as a continuity
candidate well
to me on that the SMP itself thinks so
his uh Challenger in the leadership
contest herself believed that he was one
of the most failing ministers in
government and that his record spoke for
himself
I think the bigger problem actually is
that the SMP doesn't seem to be able to
pull itself out of this and focus on the
country and the interests of the people
in the country in front of them instead
we've had this endless Merry-Go-Round of
accusations and recriminations it's
murky there have been a number of police
arrests the Mad in Scandal and there
seems to be no end in sight in the
meantime people are wondering if the
future that is on offer for their kids
is going to be anywhere like the future
that they had envisaged and they deserve
better now for a long time they didn't
have an alternative but now that labor
is ahead in the polls in the United
Kingdom there is an alternative they
could rid themselves to the Tory
government in Westminster and they could
rid themselves of this failing
government in Hollywood as well I am
I just want to talk a little bit more
about the alternative you said as you
put it as labor because look in these
interviews you know we spent time
criticizing the conservatives we spent
time criticizing the SNP and it does
feel in many ways you know the stars are
aligning for a labor Victory because of
what is happening with the other parties
but I guess some of our viewers might be
thinking
it's almost like Labor's just going to
get in by default not because you're
presenting a particularly exciting
Vision or like a great big idea for the
country but just because they're a bit
Fed Up and they've got other guys look I
think the biggest most radical thing you
could do for this country right now is
focus on the country and focus on fixing
the very many problems that people yeah
everyone would agree with that but
what's the idea of that what the idea is
that you you start to fix the
fundamentals so you take an economy that
is not working for most people that
people work harder for than ever before
and you start to invest in order to
create good jobs in every part of the
country not just some what does that do
does that mean more labels spend more
money no we've got we've got cast iron
fiscal rules that we won't borrow to
invest for day-to-day sending but we
will invest where there is a clear
interest for the country so the one
exception we've made to that rule is
that we will invest in the jobs of the
future and clean energy where there's
enormous potential for Britain and in
other growing Industries to rebuild our
Coastal and Industrial towns to get good
jobs back into communities that haven't
had them for a long time and money back
into people's pockets we could start
building more houses in this country
again if we weren't in hot to a
conservative party is
how many more houses with labor build
what are you doing to planning what what
what's the big idea we would streamline
the planning system to make sure that we
didn't have a block on new developments
particularly Around clean energy where
there's been uh this feels like
tinkering around the edges doesn't it
that's not tinkering around the edges
this country has been on the back for 13
years because we've had a government
that is in hock to a group of back
benches who are controlling government
policy even as late as this year with a
new prime minister who said he was going
to come in and build a fresh start
they've scrapped local housing targets
house building has fallen to its lowest
level since the second world war and
we've got a housing crisis and a growth
crisis in this country labor will turn
that around or relax so that will
liberalize the planning laws to make
sure that communities can make decisions
early about the sorts of Housing and
developments that that they want will
reinstate housing targets to make sure
that houses get built and will work to
provide certainty and stability so that
people can get mortgages get on the
housing ladder with a bit of help from
the state because we don't believe that
the state should step out of the way
when the market is failing that's why
labor is the answer to the challenges
that we've got and the conservative
party can't be you know listening to you
and you look at the country and and you
talk about trust and politics you're
talking about this week about you know
the state of the NHS about creating
public services but the economy new
inflation is still double digits and
we're talking about the big idea for
labor we're talking about communities
being involved a bit more easily in in
playing decisions earlier on I I just
wonder you know you're under the
leadership as well it was pretty clear
the platform that you ran on you ran on
a platform to level up and to take power
away from London what is Kirsten's
platform if you're going to sum it up
what is it so we can build a country in
which everyone has a stake and everyone
has a reward he wants to make this the
best country in the world for people to
grow grow up and grow old and at the
moment what we're seeing you mentioned
the NHS we're seeing a crown jewel
public service that was once a
destination for people all over the
world who were clamoring to come and
work in our NHS and we're now seeing us
hemorrhaging staff out to other
countries because we can't even get our
act together to make that National
Health Service fit for the future and a
place that people desperately want to
work we think we could turn that around
because in every community in this
country you find people no matter how
hard-pressed who have so much ambition
for their families their communities and
their country but what's missing is a
government that has that same level of
ambition we believe that's possible but
it can only happen where the state is
prepared to get involved roll up its
sleeves and move Heaven and Earth to
make things work instead of standing on
the sidelines as we've seen from this
government over the last 13 years
holding up their hands and saying things
can't be different they can
foreign
of the labor party if you're watching
the take we're live in Westminster up
next we have well we've yet more strikes
coming across the public sector
including civil servants being bouted
for Action we'll be speaking to the
General Secretary of the FDA Union Dave
Penman
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back live to Westminster you're
watching the take now there seems to be
no end in strike in strike there you go
there's a slave for the tongue no ending
sight to the strike crisis that's
affecting so much of the country's
public services and if anything it feels
like it's getting worse rural College of
Nursing members rejected the
government's payoff for last week
they're heading back on strike and
likely to be joined by teachers and
others and now the country's top civil
servants in the first division
Association are also could be bouncing
for strike action for the unions General
Secretary Dave Penman joins us now
thanks very much for being with us
um firstly can you just explain who it
is you represent and what impact strikes
could have
and so we represent some of the most
senior public servants in the country
and everything from the most uh
Tennessean government permanent
secretaries down to
um tax inspectors diplomats education
inspectors uh people who run our
government services and so a whole range
of senior uh professionals and managers
who are vital to the operation of most
of the kind of dialect service Civil
Service operates but also those who
facilitate what happens in health and
education and other government services
and what exactly is it that you're
calling for
so you know we were expecting to be
treated like the rest of the public
sector so elsewhere in the public sector
what the government has done is sought
to engage with unions I mean it took
some time to get the head around it that
they actually did they talked to unions
they negotiated uh they made an offer
which was about
um the coming year and also some
compensation mainly through our kind of
non-consolidated uh payment
um for previous years and the impact of
course living and that's exactly what we
would like to do was going to happen in
the civil service and then at the end of
last week uh with 12 years notice we
were called in to see the minister and
we were told that none of that was
happening there would be no offer there
would be no negotiations and crucially
there would be no further compensation
in for cost of living in a way that's
applied in both education but a thousand
pound was offered and in the NHS where
it was 1600 pounds so several seconds
once again are at the bottom of the ple
in the public sector and so that's why
we decided to take the really
unprecedented decision
um to power our members for industrial
action the first time in over 40 years
our Union has balloted our members uh
for shake actually overpaid
and I believe you've been offered a pay
rise of between 4.5 of 5 you know you
mentioned you know teachers and people
in hospitals the health sector as well I
guess teachers argue that they've had a
decade of pay restraint people in
hospitals would say look at the pressure
that they've been under during covid do
you think there's as much sympathy for
people you know in the top end of the
Civil Service like yourselves well
whether there's some you know the
reality of it as their members as public
servants are faced the same restrictions
that they have in health and education
in many ways the peace system the civil
service was because there's more kind of
annual increments that apply across the
Civil Service that's why continually
year-on-year service at salaries uh have
been at the bottom end of that of the
sort of paying places across at the
public sector we had high hopes finally
the government would treat the Civil
Service like the rest of the of the
public sector uh our members of the same
sort of Perry Street Supply
and a decade
Services if it's the same sort of
pressures when inflation is it 10 yet
for some reason the government is to say
that biostable compensate teachers they
will compensate at those who work in the
NHS and indeed there's been been deals
done in local government for some reason
their civil servants don't deserve the
same level of compensation and and we
think that's okay we can understand why
government wants to to deal with it it's
it's the very employees or of
um of ministers and other
and a different way than it does for the
rest of the public sector the idea is
the people who are solving and trying to
solve the problems in NHS who are
leading the negotiations with the
teachings are the very people the very
civil servants are now I've been treated
in this way by their own government
now if I may we are imminently expecting
a report into the conduct of Dominic
Royal the Deputy Prime Minister and he's
had allegations of uh bullying against
him he's strenuously denied he says that
he is very confident that he will be
cleared so I don't want to talk to you
about the specifics of that case it
wouldn't be right while the
investigation is ongoing
but is there a wider issue about the
relationship between politicians and
some people in the Civil Service
well absolutely we um there are some of
our of our most senior members the ones
in the senior Civil Service many of whom
come and thinking of daily contact with
ministers and one in six
said that they had had to deal with or
witness an appropriate conduct from
ministers in the last 12 months alone
and that was across 23 government
departments so yes we wait to hear what
the outcome of the investigation into
Dominic robbers but the entire system
for dealing with this is broken there is
no independent process for dealing with
this if you are a civil servant and you
complain about a minister it requires
the prime minister to agree that there's
even an investigation in only the Prime
Minister can make a decision on a
outcome so we think actually the whole
system is broken in relation to that and
and that ministers need to really
introduce what they create for public
standards have recommended and that
we've been calling for for years is a
truly independent process for regulating
um the conduct of ministers and dealing
with any complaints at the Civil Service
that's what we've got in Parliament
that's what we've got with Scottish
government and and it's high time
you quote on inappropriate conduct
really is quite
um shocking what kind of inappropriate
conducts are people talking about do you
have any sense of that yes but what they
were talking about was
um billing and harassment behavior
um amongst ministers I mean it's quite
extraordinary one in six are reporting
that sort of Conduct in the last 12
months alone and not every single civil
server would actually deal with
ministers so it told us that actually
there's a broader problem here in
government about Minister how ministers
behave and whatever the reason for that
is whether it's because they feel their
immune and to the sub scrutiny that
applies elsewhere whether the balance
and the relationship between civil
servants and ministers is wrong and they
feel that they can Empower dynamic means
that they can abuse and that
relationship whatever the causes of are
what's quite clear is that we face that
across government departments 23
separate government departments or
members reported that and this is not
about an isolated incident with an
individual Minister
um or kind of one wrote rotten apple
this suggested is a real problem across
government with a conduct and behavior
of ministers and what really civil
servants want is a way to challenge that
in a meaningful way in a way that's
independent of government we can't have
a situation would you rely on the Prime
Minister who may be in many cases
um kind of in hope to some of these
ministers I mean if you look at the
accusations against Donald Trump Dominic
Rabb was the prime minister's campaign
manager and for his uh election to be
leader of the conservative party so that
clearly calls into question whether he
is the right person to be sitting in
Judgment of any allegation against the
Deputy Prime Minister so what civil
servants really need is a fully
independent process well if they feel
that there is conduct that ministers
billing harassment there's an
independent process for dealing with
that investigating and the education an
independent process that needs to happen
in your uh words thank you very much for
being on the program today and we are
out of time without interview
you're watching uh the take next up we
are going to be rounding up everything
we've learned with our Deputy skeleton
foreign
[Music]
that we've been seeing emerging here for
some time so for much of Mr Putin's time
in office you know since uh the year
2000 what we've seen is a a steadily a
steadily increasing pattern of internal
repression and external aggression uh
within the full-blown invasion of
Ukraine last year clearly that's stepped
up
um quite a number of gears and alongside
that external aggression we've seen an
accelerating trend of internal
repression as well
so I think what we're seeing here um is
a real Crackdown on both uh internal
voices opposing that war
um and um external voices but basically
what I call it here is a war on truth
and we should see that for what it is
when the war was launched on the 24th of
February last year I think most Russians
expected to be over inside three days
and it would result in the installation
of regime friendly to um uh to the
Kremlin in Kiev that isn't of course
what happened but what I think is
happening here is really three things
and so one is silencing critics of uh Mr
Putin's you know illegal and unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine and of the internal
repression second they're looking for a
chilling effect
um on anyone um internal or
International journalists who are
prepared to spell out what's actually
happening in Russia and third this is
about creating International leverage
um over Russia's opponents so the US and
the UK and Ukraine's other International
Airlines they don't see that this
Putin's rule over Russia is likely to
come to an end anytime soon and I think
what we're seeing um is the effects the
stresses on the system of a clearly
failed strategy in Ukraine and I think
it will take some time for the effects
of that to play out domestically
I mean one of the things that I think we
should focus on here
um is looking at people like Vladimir
caramurizer the Russian British national
um who was jailed
um last week for 25 years Gerald for 25
years for the crime of criticizing
Russia's illegal and unprovoked invasion
of Ukraine
I mean he's an incredibly Brave man he's
an incredibly principled man
um and there are other people like him
in Russia I think one of the things that
we can most usefully do at this stage is
to keep open on our links to people like
Vladimir cameras or their friends their
allies Russians who want a different
sort of Russia and a different sort of
relationship between Russia and us
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello welcome back you're watching uh
the take well we've had lots of takes uh
this evening from the government labor
at the unions of course with all the
strong action that's happening have a
little bit post-match analysis now with
adaptation to some Cates who is joining
me
again
now the one story we haven't really
talked about with our guests so far
today is inflation so I really want to
talk about with you because it's such a
huge issue and it's simply not coming
down as fast as people were hoping so
above double figures I mean I made the
decision to start the interview with
Chrissy and Harris on inflation because
I do just think that actually it's the
big political uh issue of uh the moment
and it's something that certainly a lot
of people at home or everyone at home
will be feeling in different ways
um how big a problem is that sticky
inflation I think it's a massive problem
because everybody everybody feels it and
Richardson at the start of the Year
decided to make pin a bit of his
reputation on halving inflation now he
may or may not meet his Target I think
he probably still will but I wonder
whether he's gonna still feel like he's
suffering from the impacts of the
political costs of inflation
nevertheless now here on this program we
often talk about quite narrow
Westminster domestic takes on things but
one of the reasons that Rishi sunak has
a problem with inflation is to do with
the most important Global political
shift really one of the most important
Global political shifts that's going on
at the moment
um let me explain all around the world
Energy prices are affected by a lot of
things but one of the things is a group
of energy producing comp countries and
there's OPEC that um for years have
listened to America when America goes uh
Saudi Arabia could you bring down the
oil prize could you produce more oil
generally Saudi Arabia has listened as
part of a kind of historic deal to
protect their security but that pact has
been breaking down Saudi Arabia now I'm
listening more to Russia and to China
who have very different interests who in
some cases want to keep the oil price
High to fund uh moscow's war in Ukraine
the historic pact that has seen security
provided by America in the Middle East
in return for keeping low energy prices
globally he's disintegrating just at the
point where we're all using more oil and
that's feeding through into the higher
food prices and the other drivers of
domestic flesh keeping double digits in
CPI figures uh published today because
that's a massive problem the food
presentation is just jaw dropping I
think it's the highest in over 40 years
inflation roughly double at the current
headline rate of inflation and that
impacts on strikes as well right people
feeling it in their pay packets and
feeling that they need to pay rise too
you only have to look at something like
the profits the billion pound profits
multi-billion pound profits of Tesco to
realize that there is very quickly
political read across political problems
potentially coming down the track yes
teachers might not be entitled to a
double-digit pay rise as they might want
but there are other factors in there
that are complicated for politicians
very complicated something they don't
always have control over thanks very
much for your analysis and thank you for
watching the take we'll be back next
week and every week Wednesdays 9 pm it's
Garden News at 10 next
[Music]